what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and mcu and
today we got the official trailer for
the hawkeye series coming to disney plus
starring of course jeremy renner and
newcomer to the mcu haley steinfeld
playing kate bishop and we have a lot to
break down in this trailer including the
plot who exactly is haley steinfeld's
kate bishop we definitely saw ekko in
this trailer who was going to be getting
her own spin-off at disney plush show
and how about that captain america
musical that seems to be taking place
inside of the mcu we'll break it all
down in this video but if you're new be
sure to subscribe and hit that
notification bell so you don't miss out
on any of the latest videos so hawkeye
is going to be a holiday disney plus
show and i'm really really digging it so
we start off with hawkeye and his
children notice how his wife laura is
not there now considering the fact that
at some point in this trailer he does
say babe while he's talking on the phone
i assume that she is not dead but
perhaps him and his kids are on vacation
he does say he's trying to make up for
lost time and that lost time is that
five years in which his entire family
was dusted except for himself also if
you take a look at who his daughter is
this is eva russo daughter of joe russo
of the russo brothers who directed
avengers infinity war avengers in-game
captain america the winter soldier and
captain america civil war and speaking
of captain america it looks like hawkeye
this holiday season took his family to
go see rogers the musical which of
course is about steve rogers as captain
america even after he made it to the
moon i mean after he died he's still
doing pretty well in the mcu and his
musical seems to be a pretty big hit as
we can see that it's got some pretty
great reviews on these posters on the
side out front of the theater one banner
for it says a timeless story of a
timeless hero another quote says a super
powered sensation and the rest of the
reviews seem to be pretty dang good and
it looks like his family enjoyed it
however a twist comes somebody is on the
street dressing up as ronan ronin was
hawkeye's persona between the events of
avengers infinity war and avengers
in-game during that five-year gap when
his family was dusted as the news says
they're wondering if the masked
vigilante who terrorized the underworld
is back hawkeye obviously realizes that
it's not himself but somebody dressing
up as him so of course he has to attend
to this so in order to protect his
family he sends them home tells them not
to worry and tells them that he'll be
home for christmas now hawkeye says that
he made a lot of enemies when he wore
that suit we can see whoever is in the
suit running away from some men in some
tracksuits and this is the tracksuit
mafia referred to as the tracksuit
draculas in the comics but i believe in
this show they are just going by the
tracksuit mafia and they have a direct
connection with hawkeye in marvel comics
and it looks like in the hawkeye series
they're going to be after hawkeye or
ronan his alter ego for all of the
things that he did during that five year
gap but of course it's not hawkeye it's
actually kate bishop and he quickly
meets her after saving her from the
tracksuit mafia and this is where we are
introduced to haley steinfeld's
character now when he unmasks her she
says you're hawkeye and she is very very
shocked she obviously knows who he is
because she is dressed up as ronan and
we discover that she is also an archer
this leads me to believe that her story
is pretty much going to be the same as
it is in the comics if not it's going to
be pretty close in the comics at a young
age kate bishop witnesses her father
derek beating up somebody in the study
of their home from here she decided to
investigate her father's activities this
would bring her face to face with the
villain el matador who would quickly
capture her now she managed to escape
but as she was escaping his men were
coming after her but she is saved by an
arrow and the avengers the arrow
obviously came from hawkeye and from
that point in time kate bishop was kind
of obsessed with hawkeye and really
looked up to him because he was an
avenger that didn't really have any
superpowers and due to some unfortunate
events that happened in her life she was
very motivated to become proficient in
swordplay archery and martial arts which
we can see has already happened here as
she looks like she's a pretty good shot
so far but of course she hasn't been
trained by hawkeye yet so she's about to
get a lot better now once when hawkeye
realizes that it's kate bishop dressed
up as his former self ronan he decides
that well she's just too young for him
to just leave to deal with the tracksuit
mafia so now we have the dynamic duo in
the hawkeye series of hawkeye and kate
bishop now it seems like she thinks her
skills are pretty good as she says some
people have actually called me the
world's greatest archer now she
definitely knows that this is hawkeye so
this could be her attempt at getting
hawkeye to actually try and help her
which seems to work the next scene we
see is of hawkeye and kate and hawkeye
asks kate are you one of those people in
which she shakes her head yes now i
don't really think this is pertaining
that much to the plot of the story if
you look at the background of the place
that they're about to walk into you can
see a bunch of pizza boxes they're most
likely about to go get some pizza which
leads me to believe that kate bishop is
probably one of those people who likes
pineapple on pizza and that is probably
the joke here hawkeye is really asking
are you one of those people who likes
pineapple on pizza in which kate bishop
says yes we then see the scene i talked
about where hawkeye picks up the phone
and says hey babe i should be back in
one or two days obviously hawkeye is not
going to leave kate bishop just to die
because as it's very clear here the
tracksuit mafia is still after now both
of them hawkeye's reflexes are still
just as good as before as one of the
members of the tracksuit mafia throws a
molotov cocktail at the window in which
hawkeye and kate bishop are in the
building he quickly breaks the window
catches the bottle throws it back at him
and lights them on fire their tracksuits
and all and from here we see that
hawkeye's not exactly having the best
time trying to get rid of this mafia off
his back he's got several bruises on his
body so does kate bishop he's ziplining
and it breaks but as you can see there's
another zip line down below which he's
probably going to catch hawkeye says
things have gotten a little more
complicated and we can see him put a lot
of ice packs all over his body clearly
taking care of kate and dealing with the
tracksuit mafia has proven a little bit
harder than he thought it would be he's
getting beat up he's getting shot at and
he's getting kidnapped but don't worry
kate bishop is quickly coming to the
rescue sort
of now from here we see a lot of quick
action sequences but one thing that's
very important to note here is we see
vera farmiga's character eleanor bishop
the mother of kate bishop now in the
comics it was believed that eleanor
bishop died when kate was very very
young however later on it was actually
revealed that she was alive and
directing the activities of kate's
nemesis in the comics madame mask madam
mask has caused lots of trouble for tony
stark shield and others over time and
she's also cloned herself several times
as well and it looks like eleanor and
madam mask could be the true villains
behind everything that we're seeing in
the hawkeye series because the tracksuit
mafia is cool but there's got to be a
bigger villain than them and since they
showed eleanor here i'm going to assume
that she's going to be the big villain
and probably madame mask as well as we
go on we get a shot of the rogers
musical and we can see that all of the
original avengers are there some chitari
and then some more so it looks like the
musical is going to be covering events
from captain america's first journey all
the way to the avengers all the way to
avengers infinity war we then get a shot
of lucky the dog in the comics arrow was
the original name of the dog and arrow
actually belonged to somebody of the
tracksuit mafia however clint showed him
some kindness and aero repaid the favor
by attacking some of the men of the
tracksuit mafia however he paid a price
the tracksuit mafia beat him up threw
him onto the street but hawkeye saved
him rushed him to the vet unfortunately
he lost an eye but he did make a full
recovery besides that and he would go on
to become clint's dog renaming him lucky
kate would eventually go away and take
lucky with her but when she found out
about the tracksuit mafia's plan to kill
clint her and lucky come back to try and
save hawkeye i can't wait to see him he
better not die and also he loves pizza
we then get a scene of hawkeye and kate
bishop dressed up as ronin in what
appears to be some sort of medieval fair
reenactment of a battle it looks like
kate bishop is celebrating and we can
obviously see hawkeye kick and butt on
the field this will most likely be a
pretty comedic scene probably towards
the latter half of the series i'm
assuming because hawkeye and kate bishop
are together from here we see a lot of
scenes of the tracksuit mafia after kate
and clint and in a real quick moment we
can see the new character ekko aka maya
lopez who is going to be played by
alaqua cox ekko is going to be a deaf
superhero in the marvel cinematic
universe the very first one and alaqua
cox is deaf herself so this is a pretty
cool historic moment right here in the
comics she starts off as bad but then
becomes good and she also kind of has
task master ability she has the
abilities to mimic people so she's
definitely going to be a treat for the
show and as i mentioned she's getting
her own spin-off series which is heavily
rumored to feature daredevil and fisk so
she's not going anywhere anytime soon
now we end with two pretty awesome
scenes clint and kate are in a car being
chased and shot at by some members of
the tracksuit mafia but hawkeye is still
trying to do the best he can to be a
mentor to kate so he's telling her that
some arrows are off limits definitely
not this one this one's too dangerous
until he eventually does give her an
arrow in which she looks a lot like
taskmaster shooting and the arrow
actually looks like one that taskmaster
used as well because she shoots it and
the car behind her immediately explodes
she asks hawkeye there are arrows more
dangerous than that one and he kind of
just smirks it off as we've seen
throughout time in the mcu hawkeye has a
lot of different arrows and some of them
actually are pretty cool and very
dangerous unfortunately kate bishop
isn't going to be as cool as hawkeye
until she can shoot without even looking
at what she's shooting at but don't
worry because hawkeye is going to be
teaching her that the very last scene
that we get is of kate and clint jumping
off of a bridge safely into water and it
looks like hawkeye is trying to teach
kate his classic jump off of a building
turn around while grabbing an arrow and
shoot while falling move considering the
fact that it doesn't look like they're
being shot at and there's water behind
them it looks like this most likely is
clint teaching kate how to do that she's
probably studied him over time since she
looks up to him and she probably asked
him how to do that because she wants to
learn and if you look closely it doesn't
look like she's actually getting the
move down but i'm sure by the end of the
series she will and that is the hawkeye
trailer it's coming out on november 24th
we have a release date be sure to let me
know what you thought about this trailer
in the comments down below let me know
how excited you are for it and what your
favorite part was don't forget to like
the video and for live updates you can
always follow me on instagram and
twitter and as always thank you all so
much for watching
woof
me